frau schimke wie viel unterstützung hat
diese impfpflicht aktuell bei ihnen zu
hause in ostdeutschland also wir müssen
sie suchen die unterstützung ich meine
es gibt natürlich menschen die das
befürworten aber so gefühlt in meinem
persönlichen umfeld ist natürlich die
ablehnung sei groß aber weise
entschuldung ich bin entsetzt wir reden
hier über eine impfpflicht über eine
mögliche mutation die irgendwann mal
kommt das wissen wir doch im moment noch
gar nicht wir können doch nicht eine
massive grundrechts einschränkung eine
verletzung oder oder oder eine ja eine
eine verletzung über die entscheidung
über die persönliche gesundheit jetzt
vornehmen ohne zu wissen wie sich dieses
virus entwickelt das kann man doch nicht
machen das ist doch nicht politisch
verantwortet das kann man machen wenn
man der argumentation vom chef des
robert-koch-instituts herrn viel erfolg
der sagte am freitag in dieser
pressekonferenz mit lauterbach begründet
er das und sagt am ende wird die
impfpflicht tote verhindern in
deutschland glauben sie dass er das kann
ja möglicherweise seien aber die
argumentation gegen eine impfpflicht ist
doch immer die dass sich diese
entscheidung am ende selbst zu treffen
habe über mein leben das tue ich wenn
ich mich entscheide zu rauchen das tue
ich wenn ich mich entscheide alkohol zu
trinken oder mit hoch speed über die
piste zu fahren ja und gleiches gilt
auch für ein virus wir können die
menschen dazu nicht verpflichtet haben
sie dass das tote für das sie im pflicht
tote verhindert er weiß dass das weiß
keiner glauben sie dass rechnen sie das
rechnen sie damit auch herr hologic herr
dürr hologic
ich glaube dass wir schwere
krankheitsverläufe verhindern können ich
glaube dass wir unsere krankenhäuser
entlasten können das notwendige
operationen stattfinden und ich hoffe
mir dass die bundesregierung einen
entwurf vorlegt das wird es jetzt auf
den weg bringen andere länder machen
sonst vor in österreich ist die
impfpflicht schon im nationalrat bei uns
diskutiert man über bürokratie und über
andere dinge so was kann ein land wie
wir eigentlich nicht zulassen wir wer
denn jetzt über diese ethisch
juristischen fragen diskutieren müssen
und wir brauchen eine entscheidung
zaudern und zögern zögern ist in dieser
frage für mich nicht der richtige
maßstab herdorfer hindert die
impfpflicht tote glauben sie das auch so
wie der lka chef das sagt
wir wissen es nicht genau das ist doch
die wahrheit und deswegen hat der
kollege dick wie sie das im vollkommen
richtig beschrieben eine mögliche
endlich das ist sorgfältig abzuwägen
weil es ein freiheits eingriff ist der
möglicherweise andritz freiheit wieder
ermöglicht mich beispielsweise
operationen durchzuführen die notwendig
sind von menschen die sie eben ganz
dringend brauchen also diese freiheit
abwägung stattfinden und der satz
richtig gesagt eine mögliche impfpflicht
wird gegen eine weitere welle im herbst
und deswegen sollten uns diese zeit der
moderne checke ich verstehe erneut nicht
dieses politik marketing an der stelle
es ärgert mich muss ich sagen auch es
geht doch nicht darum jetzt eine
entscheidung aus der hüfte heraus zu
treffen eine so schwerwiegende wie die
kollegen im team zu recht gesagt hat
soll das muss man ab wie man muss
öffentlich diskutieren und vor allem
sich überlegen welche konsequenzen man
aus der mikrowelle zieht denn wir lernen
ganz ganz viele verweise haben es zu
anfang gesagt in bezug auf
großbritannien und dieses wissen dieses
lernen müssen wir doch in eine solche
abwägung mit einfließen lassen deswegen
plädiere ich dazu uns dass wir uns die
zeit dafür nehmen dass wir dieses
quartal ausnutzen und die debatte zu
führen und alles experten wissen
zusammenzutragen aber einig dass im
freistaat aber noch wesentlich
deswegen noch mal die frage auch an sie
wenn das so wichtig ist mit der
impfpflicht wenn das so
erfolgsversprechend vor allen dingen ist
das plötzlich in den landkreisen auch wo
sie ganz niedrige impfquoten haben in
thüringen in sachsen wenn sie dort
ernsthaft damit rechnen dass sich die
menschen dann anschließend und an der
impfpflicht impfen lassen wenn diese
impfpflicht tatsächlich tote verhindern
wird schwere krankheitsverläufe
verhindern wird wie kann man das als
kanzler sagen das überlasse ich den
bundestag
ist es bewusst die entscheidung
getroffen worden dass es sich hier um
eine ethische frage handelt und wenn man
eine ethische debatte im deutschen
bundestag führt dann ist es so dass dann
letztendlich die vorschläge wie das
geregelt werden soll aus der mitte des
deutschen bundestages kommt und ich sage
auch fraktionsübergreifend ich lade auch
die kolleginnen und kollegen und cdu/csu
ein sich in diese debatte aktiv
einzubringen ich glaube dass wir hier
fraktionsübergreifend zu einer breiten
mehrheit kommen um dann auch das schaue
ich zu gern holetschek was die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gemeinsam
mit olaf scholz ja beschlossener dort
hat man 16 0 1 der gemeinde eben
schlicht befürwortet wir werden diese
debatte im deutschen bundestag jetzt
angehen wir werden sie gründlich angehen
aber wir werden sie auch zügig angehen
und in der ersten quartal genau wie es
der kollege der gesagt hat zu einer
entscheidung ob wiese ich empfinde das
als ein stück weit ja ein stück weit
unehrlich von den regierungsfraktionen
sie haben sich nicht einigen können in
der koalition weil es bei ihnen wie es
auch draußen im land wie es in den
familien unterschiedliche meinungen gibt
was völlig normal ist aber sie haben
sich in der koalition nicht einigen
können auf diesem weg impfpflicht und
jetzt sagen sie das ist eine ethische
debatte das kann nur im bundestag
verabschiedet werden ihn ist es aber so
wichtig angeblich dass sie es unbedingt
haben wollen also sagen sie doch der
mensch mensch wir haben uns nicht
einigen können in der ampel deswegen
muss es in den bundestag ein das wäre
doch ehrlich hätte herr wiese
noch mal ich halte die entscheidung für
richtig dass man hier letztendlich den
fraktionszwang an der stelle auf geht
das kann man kritisieren diese kritik
nehme ich auch zur kenntnis das ist gar
keine frage aber nochmal ich halte die
entscheidung für richtig bei dieser
sensiblen frage die breite debatten in
der bevölkerung mehr auslöst auch mit
unterschiedlichen argumentationen weil
sie es für richtig dass in dieser art
und weise im deutschen bundestag zu
einer entscheidung zu
bitten
ich habe als wenn ich da ergänzen darf
also ich kann es auf meine person ja mal
beziehen ich selbst bin
bundestagsabgeordnete und noch nicht in
der sache entschieden ich bin noch nicht
festgelegt ich bin noch nicht pro in
pflicht- oder gegen weil ich aussage ist
könnte unter umständen auch abstufungen
graustufen stufen geben wie
beispielsweise eine altersbezogene
impfpflicht und deswegen will ich mir
diese zeit aufnehmen und ich glaube das
gehört zur ehrlichkeit dazu dass wir den
menschen sagen wir wissen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht alles und deswegen
komme ich zu der überzeugung jetzt noch
nicht zu sagen wo ich stehe ich werde
das tun das ist mein versprechen im
ersten quartal aber diese zeit bin ich
mir auch nehmen und ich glaube das trägt
er dazu bei dass politik und auch
politische entscheidung akzeptieren sie
schon in ihrer fraktion herr dr ob star
aber er halt aktuell gibt sie haben es
als fraktionsvorsitzender im blick sie
wissen wie die abgeordneten ticken in
ihren reihen manche mögen sie noch nicht
festgelegt haben genau wie sie aber
haben sie da aktuell eine mehrheit für
die impfpflicht in ihren eigenen reihen
wir machen ja keine gewissensfrage
sondern werden und wenn man sich ja mal
hat ein übergreifen darüber zu reden und
auch entlang von julia in grenzen das
macht auch sinn bei so einer ethischen
frage man spricht auch miteinander man
weiß doch wie der kollege kubik kritik
wie sie werden von vielen anderen
kollegen und ihr genau wissen
ich gebe ihnen da gerne einblick da sind
kollegen dabei die sagen ich war
skeptisch in bezug auf eine impfpflicht
ich sehe es jetzt sich differenzierter
zum beispiel eine altes bezogen im
pflicht könnte ein weg sein andere
kollegen sagen im dezember war ich eher
finance pflicht jetzt sehe ich das
differenzierter das eventuell gar nicht
so wahnsinnig viel bringt wie
ursprünglich besprochen es werden wege
ehrlichkeit dass man sich das schwer
macht eine solche entscheidung ich finde
das trägt er zur akzeptanz von politik
bei als man es unter den teppich kehrt
und sowie hologic sagt schnell schnell
man muss jetzt mal entscheiden und dann
wird das schon dass hier
es werden die fraktionen die dafür sind
für die impfpflicht politik ganz kurz um
diesen blog einmal abzurunden rechnen
sie damit dass wir jetzt in diesem
quartal bis ostern beispielsweise eine
impfpflicht bekommen
also ich will noch mal klipp und klar
sagen das thema muss chefsache ist eine
sache des kanzler sein und von daher
wehrführung fordert bekommt der muss sie
dann auch annehmen muss haben wir reden
jetzt schon über wärme eine einrichtungs
bezogene lassen sie mich das kurzen
ausfällen weil es wichtig ist wir haben
jetzt eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht wir haben viele menschen die
sagen warum sind wir jetzt dran in der
pflege in den krankenhäusern und es gibt
keine allgemeine impfpflicht wir
brauchen da jetzt eine entscheidung
wegen mir machen wir die befristet die m
fliegt oder wir stufen sie nach alter ab
aber es muss jetzt diskutiert und
entschieden werden und man kann es doch
erwarten dass wir aus der pandemie
kommen jetzt nicht wieder in einer
endlosschleife der diskussion sind kommt
die impfpflicht oder kommt sie nicht
womit rechnen wir berechnen
ich rechne damit dass sie kommt
herr wiese können sie sagen dass ich
dann unter einer impfpflicht am ende 70
millionen deutsche werden impfen lassen
ich hoffe dass die impfpflicht dazu
beitragen wird dass wir für den
kommenden herbst und winter eine höhere
im quoten haben als jetzt man muss aber
auch leider realistisch einschätzen es
gibt einen harten kern von impfgegnern
den werden wir letztendlich nicht
erreichen also wir werden sicherlich
nicht 100% im spur zu bekommen aber
nochmal und das will ich einmal noch
unterstreichen und da auch einmal
widersprechen das impfen ist nicht nur
eine persönliche entscheidung in dem
moment wo ich es schaffe die impfquote
zu erhöhen trage ich dazu bei dass sich
eine entlastung in den krankenhäusern
hinbekomme und der zeit verschobene
operationen die krebspatienten
abgesagt werden was was das zutiefst
ethisch und moralisch ist da müssen wir
hinbekommen dass diese planbaren
operationen stattfinden können dass wir
diese pandemie im rahmen einer
endemischen lage beherrschbar machen und
darum ist impfen nicht nur eine
privatsache das ist eine art
absolutistischer freiheitsbegriff den
ich nicht teile